I'm lettin cable get to team I could be
of great use what's your superpower that
is that's adorable
it's time to get back on LinkedIn
[Music]
beats Peter any power want to tell us
about I have both type 1 and 2 diabetes
as it turns out we are looking for
someone with diabetes Peters your man
believe it or not
Deadpool 2 is a family film
can you come out to go its my
anniversary
there's this kid he's in trouble
Russell right i--i first that kids got a
terrible name it's awful
I've tried to tell him he though we gen
here's this plan oh go tall save the kid
come on make a super baby pretty sure it
doesn't work that way but we can try
okay hey now we're behind the scenes of
the new Deadpool to music video starring
Celine Dion's hologram I don't know why
they didn't just send the real Celine
well I dunno restraining what is it
anyway I little nervous today I haven't
done any dancing since I moved out from
Canada in 98 and that was between two
dumpsters between going goodbye so I
need to really up my game here
they had five bones from my body removed
including my collarbones seven inches to
spine it's all just be a little bit
fluid are they're real the boobs yeah -
but mine - she thinks of spider-man
anyway hey everybody its charlie she
thinks I'm spider-man
of course Celine Dion would probably
mixed up like that up if you didn't know
they actually did a real-deal music
video I have no idea why they chose to
do an integration with Celine Dion
obviously they're promoting the movie so
they're just doing all kinds of crazy
stuff and promos like they did for the
last big Deadpool movie but I think a
lot of that is them ramping up for the
Eurovision contest like they just
dropped a promo saying that they would
be promoting the movie at Eurovision if
you're not from the UK you don't know
what that is it's kind of like a version
of American Idol on steroids so
apparently they're gonna be doing
something during that but they're a
bunch of Easter eggs that they drop
during this and they confirmed a bunch
of stuff during the legit part of that
trailer so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos depending on where you
live in the world Deadpool is dropping
next week it kind of came up on us
because we've been spending so much time
talking about infinity war but surprise
brand-new Deadpool movie coming out then
right after that we have ant-man and the
wasp but Ryan Reynolds actually just
dropped another infinity war joke if you
remember the Thanos demands your silence
campaign that the Russo started before
the movie came out so the one the
Deadpool sent out has the Fox logo at
the top just marked out to be determined
because Disney's in the process of
buying them we've embarked on the
Deadpool - this is kind of your guys
fault world tour
almost everyone involved in the film has
given maximum effort the past two years
maintaining the highest level of super
secrets like how David Blaine catches
bullets in his mouth in the secret blend
of 11 herbs and spices in Colonel
Sanders delicious moustache only a
handful of people know this film's true
plot one of them is not Ryan Reynolds
we're asking that when you see Deadpool
- don't say a word about the fun [ __ ] in
the movie cuz it'd be super lame to
spoil the fact that Deadpool died
in this one kidding not kidding but
kidding like big question mark like you
don't know what happens to him obviously
he's gonna be an X force so he's not
gonna die and within reason Deadpool is
functionally immortal because of his
powers unless you chop his head off he
also did this funny Google search tie-in
whereby if you ask it certain questions
about Deadpool Ryan Reynolds he'll
answer them in videos in the costume as
the character are you asking because he
couldn't line up a date or is it because
you're not 17 yet either way the answer
is yes absolutely he also earned
critical acclaim for his role in the
notebook in the TV series young Hercules
Claire witty superhero wears a red suit
friendly neighborhood kind of guy who
lives as an old woman might shoot webs I
use a hammer but I don't recommend that
that's easy
torture them pills I mean you know
usually it's lots and lots of pills
that's often you know chased with a
spirit like gin or Oh meditate medicate
as cool and moist as a dolphin's
blowhole baby don't hurt me don't hurt
me no more
why is the Sun flat look I'm not a
scientist if I'm looking at a globe well
I'd say no but if I'm looking at a crisp
map laid out on a desk I'd say no
absolutely
I suggest texting them every 4 minutes
until you die alone it's all in the legs
so make sure you've really been working
on those thighs otherwise you'll never
get high enough and you'll wind up going
straight through the friendly
neighborhood guy that lives with an old
woman might shoot some webs just making
more spider-man jokes but as for the
brand-new footage that just dropped
dopinder formally joining x-force there
were shots of him standing inside
Deadpool in blind Al's apartment so it
seemed like he was in on the team anyway
because most of the first movie was just
him riding around in the cab and even
though he's still doing that
when you see him standing around with
everyone else talking about what looks
like x4 stuff it just implies that he's
on the team we learned that Peter has
all kinds of diabetes Julianne Denison's
character calls himself out as fire fist
now that is the Russell Collins
character in the comics was who he
thought he was playing but we just knew
him as Russell so it's like okay
his powers work a lot like fire fist
that's probably who he is this just
confirms that we get a joke about
Deadpool making a superbaby the writers
of the movie revealed that when they
were first trying to break the story a
long time ago like right after the first
movie came out what are we gonna do for
the sequel what would happen if Deadpool
had a kid they immediately threw that
idea out that's garbage Deadpool does
not need a child so they still make a
lot of jokes about that in the film and
Russell is kind of like a kid that he
takes care of but that's as close as
they get to the idea of Deadpool taking
care of someone even if you're not a big
comic book reader I think we can all
agree it's probably a good idea they
didn't actually try to give Deadpool a
child but they just them on the couch
talking about family stuff so you can
see he's thinking about that they'll
probably have a lot of jokes about it
but this shot here of the henchmen
checking him out on the surveillance
might be from earlier in the film like
you see him running for dopinder Scavo
right after he gets done with a hit this
might be what that hit is that precedes
it the anniversary that he's talking
about is probably what he was late for
in the trailers that we've seen so far
sorry I was trying to round up all the
glue
and fired into outer space so that it
couldn't hurt us he improv most of that
Celine Dion behind-the-scenes video just
riffing stuff but he did drop a couple
Easter eggs so he makes the joke about
moving from Canada in 98 deadpool
debuted in humans 98 so there's just a
reference to that
ryan reynolds had already been a very
active actor by 1998 he makes the joke
about living between two dumpsters when
he first moved to town between cohen and
vine there's just a place in los angeles
that's not known for being very clean so
he's just making a joke about being a
starving actor this isn't Ryan Reynolds
doing all this dancing like he makes the
joke about having a couple of his bones
removed so that he could be more bendy
that's actually this guy but if they are
going to the Eurovision contest they
might actually have one of the
contestants dress up in a Deadpool
costume but remains to be seen so like I
said because the movies coming out next
week they're in full swing with the
press tour there's gonna be more crazy
stuff dropping in the next week or two
just leave your requests in the comments
below I believe that I'm allowed to post
my non-spoilery review a couple days
before the movie comes out I have to
double check what the embargo is what
are you wait for everything click here
to listen to the Russo's talk about why
the Hulk was so messed up during
infinity war and click here for
brand-new Deadpool thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]